what a weekend this has been i know i
know i feel so excited today
from friday night to this morning big
news it's a big big day for all of us in
america we welcome you to cbs this
morning because today
is the start of the biggest vaccination
effort in u.s history
trucks carrying the coronavirus vaccine
left fiser's facility in michigan
yesterday
to big big applause the first wave
includes 2.9 million doses
initial shipments will reach 145
distribution centers
all over the country today the vaccine
can't come soon enough with the overall
u.s
death toll expected to rise above 300
000 in the next 24 hours it's currently
just over 299
thousand our lead national correspondent
david begno is at university of
california davis medical center
in sacramento david we understand the
first doses could be given to health
care workers there in just a matter of
hours how's the hospital getting ready
anthony they thought they'd get the
doses today but now it looks like they
won't get it until tomorrow they're
still waiting on the tracking number
and that is exactly what hospital
institutions around the country right
now are doing
waiting on that fedex tracking number or
ups tracking
we're downstairs in the pharmacy area
this is where the vaccines will go more
than 5 000 doses
negative 76 degrees celsius you open it
up
and there it goes you see the frost
coming out an impressive freezer
already fired up ready to go chad
hatfield the chief pharmacy officer
he's the guy waiting on the tracking
number that they thought was coming
today
but still hasn't gotten here the first
patient is on standby
how do you feel about getting the shot
how are you feeling right now
i want to call my hands i'm so excited
i've been waiting for this
eva teniola who's been a nurse for 15
years is
anxiously standing by for that call
which so many healthcare workers have
been waiting for
she is going to be the first person to
get the coronavirus vaccine
at uc davis as a caregiver i witnessed
like the worst like scenario that's why
i've been
waiting for this vaccine because i
believe this would end
this pandemic thank pandemic she says
she's doing it for the safety of her own
family
including her son rafael she's been told
that when the call comes they want her
at the hospital
in 30 minutes what we have here is an
amazing setup
it is basically an assembly line dr
david lebarsky is ceo of uc davis health
why such a race well every single day
matters
he says they plan to vaccinate about 1
000 frontline workers
every day starting with those who work
in the emergency department this is
probably
the most exciting day of 2020 maybe the
most exciting day
in the last 20 years the number of
people who are
dying every single day is huge and the
vaccine
is our way back pfizer partnered with uc
davis back in august to carry out part
of their vaccine trial
testing the vaccine these four people
were all involved
none are aware of whether they got the
real thing or the placebo
but jessica holstrom and nicolette
santiago say they had symptoms that
lasted about a day or two
i had really intense chills a little bit
of nausea
headache a lot of just shivering
for professor rafael sanchez and dr
david cook
the side effects were minimal what would
you all say to americans who will watch
this and say
you know i don't want to be the first so
i get a lot of
statements from my patients over the
years saying i don't want to be a guinea
pig
especially my patients of color from
communities that historically
have cause and reason not to trust
health care yet
i volunteered for this trial so you can
take this vaccine
and help turn the tide in your
communities
you know dr cook told us we were the
guinea pigs so you don't have to be
this is it this is the room where the
vaccines will happen
socially distanced of course as for why
uc davis is going so fast to start the
vaccinations
they've had 800 workers get sick 200 of
them are actually out
right now and tony you know when it
comes to actually that fedex tracking
number i was talking about you know how
they're tracking it just like you track
christmas gifts
put in that number and watch the plane
fly
pretty big stocking stuff for david
thank you very much we're all looking
forward to it